the White House scrambling to avoid
another travel meltdown this Memorial
Weekend experts think it could be one of
the busiest on record but the FAA
warning that a major Staffing shortage
of air traffic controllers could fuel
delays and canceled flights it's
something the bite administration had a
whole lot of time to fix but don't worry
people to judge is on the case and ready
to deflect
you were very hard on the airlines about
their staffing issues a year later ATC
is still having its own staffing issues
why hasn't that gotten fixed well look
we're going to own anything that's under
our control we're talking about five
percent of the issue we're hiring up
Staffing up meanwhile the airlines which
are responsible for a much greater share
of the delays and cancellations have
made improvements since we really put
that pressure on them a year ago
Joe Biden has a website the president
touting his new effort to compensate
Travelers for flight delays tweeting
quote heads up for travelers this
Memorial Day we launched
flightbrights.gov if your flight was
canceled or delayed because of an
airline you can check the dashboard to
see how you could be compensated mayor
Pete also pumping up the website
there are stories of folks sitting on
that tarmac for seven eight nine hours
and unless you had some sort of status
on that Airline you got nothing
for it flightrights.gov and you can see
Airline by Airline who's going to cover
your meal who's going to give you uh
extra compensation who's going to rebook
you no matter what and that transparency
is part of how we got the airlines to
make more enforceable commitments about
what they would do
I'm just getting mad um I know already
so let me start with you Joey is the way
to understand Pete Buda judge's actions
and inactions to just understand that if
you look at it through the prison that
his whole goal is to get you to actually
fly less and drive less it all makes
sense well maybe I I get the green
energy I get where you're going I think
it's just absolute fundamental Democrat
policy ideas rather than fix a problem
we'll just give you some money so you'll
deal with it rather than getting you to
where you want to go we're just going to
make sure you get reimbursed maybe
sprinkle a little cash on top that we
can get there you know rather than
starting a business and going out and
risking and making a fortune we'll just
keep you on the government down with
social welfare programs it's how they do
business we're going to create a website
and get some cash in our pocket it
doesn't matter that we're not going to
be able to get you where you're trying
to go that's just kind of the mentality
there of we're all a victim just
compensate us and we'll go home and be
okay about it but but you know he says
oh it's only five percent of what's
going on in the in the aftermath of the
Airline problems last year he was
supposed to go in and regulate the
airlines more to have them in a better
place and now his song is well
whatever's under my control I'll own but
the rest of it you know 95 percent of
it's on them well who's the regulating
Authority for them granted there's some
Commerce and and probably uh Financial
parts to that that aren't necessarily
under his authority but who's going to
bring the people to the table if not him
you know Jessica part of the problem is
there's an airline traffic controller
shortage right and so instead of just
saying let's just get the best and and
by the way that we used to actually look
at just the best for this important job
he's looking at it and we have all the
the evidence that he's been looking at
it through a diversity lens like let's
just make Airline traffic controllers
more diverse instead of let's just get
more of the best
I don't know about that aspect of it I I
haven't seen anything that said that
people judge is only on the hunt for
black Trans air traffic controllers or
whatever disability I think looking for
blind and uh anyone I don't think that
there is a straight line between
Dei and incompetence I I think that it
has been proven time and time again that
it doesn't make people or organizations
less successful because they have
represented well thought out
representation that reflects the country
and that people are given opportunities
that they haven't been given for decades
if not longer I'm curious where all the
covid money went and we say this about
the schools as well right there are
billions of dollars that have been
handed out they went to the airlines
saved all the major airlines
so we really shouldn't be having these
kinds of problems
anymore and I'm curious George you and
Tyrus are the biggest Flyers who are
sitting at the table
how would you fix this well he's the
biggest flyer oh sorry he's gonna make
the mid-size flyer at the table and then
so would you are you gonna are you gonna
use the website if you're delayed
flightrades.com
why does the government continue to
insult us with websites and apps yeah it
doesn't work people on the border oh
there's an app for you to fill out your
amnesty work and they have no signal so
now it's Memorial Day weekend I've got
six kids you have like double that and
we're sitting on a plane and the planes
canceled and you're gonna tell me and my
screaming kids
and my wife's going nuts for me to get
on the app and I'm going to be
compensated is there a time machine on
the app is going to take our time back
exactly and then when poor grandma
doesn't get to see her little babies the
whole weekend's ruined and then when
here's the best part when are you going
to get the money oh six to eight weeks
so just in time for you to pay taxes
with that money like it's a complete
joke the answer and the problem and I
just I try not to attack the other side
of the aisle but Buddhist is just
terrible in the words of Charles Barkley
terrible the man showed up to the train
wreck in dress shoes okay like he just
doesn't get it they it's not an app you
throw all kinds of money it doesn't work
you have it's like firefighters air
traffic controllers doctors I want the
best I don't care what color is I don't
care who they sleep with I don't want
someone who's on the hire them get them
in there give them their money take that
money you were going to give me for
being stuck
to tell you there are air traffic
controller whistleblowers who have come
out and and made the point that they're
actually afraid
um that safety has been compromised by
Dei policies but Jessica did bring up
the money and she said where's the
coveted money that's absolutely right we
also had an infrastructure bill that
turned out to just be a climate bill so
I mean this is more and more of of the
priorities of people to judge on the
left coming out he's not doing his job
he's promoting other things well
remember we have the FAA administrator
nominee withdraw after really tough
questioning on the hill when people who
did have backgrounds as pilots and
others were saying what about this
safety space one of the story like he
couldn't answer any of the questions
apparently he had successfully run the
Denver International Airport but his
showing was so bad in the Senate that
they decided we're not even going to
advance this guy and he pulled out so
they have key positions that are open
um that need somebody in there if you're
going to oversee some of these other
problems air traffic controllers and
others
um he had a tough time in the Senate so
who's decks yeah it's it's a great
question are you going to use the
website Shannon if you're delayed I
honestly I will not I fly every week I'm
always going somewhere I just have to
say people have gone completely crazy on
planes I was on one not long ago where
they literally came over the speaker and
said
um everybody look under your feet
there's a cat on the loose that has got
now in somewhere that sounds fun and
they said if you want to just grab the
cat and get it just bring it up we'll
get it back to the owner and then they
came on with a bunch of people started
screaming about that and said if you
don't like cats or you're allergic
you're afraid of getting scratched don't
touch it just let us know when we'll
come get it I'm like air traffic has
just gotten completely ridiculous yeah
air travel has changed it's not as
dignified as it used to they did find
the cabinet hey the people who do the
jobs give them the money the traffic
controllers the pilots the attendants
the TSA the luggage guys pay them make
them want to come to work I love it the
cat Wranglers okay and the cat Wranglers
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else